let's go to
vince from wisconsin vince you're on the
air what's on your mind
oh david um i'm just wondering what do
you think what punishment do you think
the ring leaders of the coup should
receive like trump ali cruz giuliani
these people depends what i mean listen
is it this is a question really for
prosecutors you have to figure out first
of all did they commit any crimes if
they committed crimes what can you prove
in court and so i i just don't know and
this is part of why i've said i don't
think that the general insiders are
going to suffer any consequences because
it's not clear to me what specific
crimes you you could actually
successfully charge them with uh we all
know
that they
spent months
fomenting an environment where they had
ignorant rage-filled people weaponized
and ready to go completely crazy on
january 6th but i don't know that that
is a clear path towards any specific
charges which is why i don't think
they're going to be charged
do you think that maybe a part of a
reason why prosecutors won't charge is
that they might be afraid of of the
coming to essentially harden them having
their families no i don't think so i
think that i for me i've said before
i believe if one prosecutor charged
trump
there would be more prosecutors that
would be ready but it's i understand
that there are likely prosecutors who
don't want to be the first to charge a
former president because that is a
really really big deal in the context of
american democracy but no i don't think
the reason they aren't charging these
people is because they're worried about
their families i just think that it's
not completely clear they think any of
the charges will stick
yeah i just reading the other day that
uh uh the new york charges are
sort of fizzling out nothing's really
going on with that well but that that's
a different situation what appears to be
happening with the manhattan d.a is that
prosecutors quit
because they became aware that the d.a
didn't really seem to have any intention
of charging trump and they were like
well what the hell are we doing
investigating that that's a that's a
different situation i would say correct
what's the deal yeah well
it just seems like you know in this
country you only get consequence rich
rich and powerful people only receive
consequences if they screw over other
rich richer and more powerful people
there are definitely there's a two-tier
justice system in the united states
that's for sure
right and even even if i think they
should at least try even if it doesn't
succeed but
because then you set the president that
you can you can be charged you can
prosecute them that's that's up for
debate i mean if if you don't believe
the charges will stick and that they
will go anywhere there's risk both
personally to prosecutors and and um
systemically to starting to charge
former presidents with stuff you don't
really think you can get them on so i
don't know i think some legal experts
would disagree with you on that
yeah if it's a low chance they maybe
they shouldn't but if it's a decent
chance then it you know it might make
future people future presidents
uh you know think twice about doing this
stuff i agree if you think you can
demonstrate it in court even if you're
not going to get a guilty verdict but if
you think you can seriously demonstrate
in court the wrongdoing
which often includes proving state of
mind which can be tough i completely
agree with you then charges should be
brought
yeah it's just it's just disheartening
to me but thanks for taking my call my
pleasure thank you very much that's
vince from wisconsin
let's go
uh next
two where are we going next
let's go to peleg from israel peleg you
are on the air
hello david uh it's my second time
calling in i remember last year on the
october 17th jail talking to you it's
great to talk to you again likewise
um so my question is uh more general
about um
um
in developed countries or in developing
countries i should say um what do you
think is the best way to strengthen
democracy there and build up a system
that is desirable
you are are you saying many developing
countries are democratic so can you
clarify are you saying in per in
particular developing countries that are
not democratic
yes also um
like um helping them economically to
build social democracy there um and
generally a desirable economic system
i mean the thing about the question is
it presumes that we need to be helping
every country i mean there there's lots
of countries that are developing but
we're you know we're doing business with
them we're
helping them in terms of industry by
buying things from them i don't know i
think it's a little presumptive to
assume we need to be doing more
necessarily i think that i would first
say prove to me we should be doing
anything
oh i i meant through trade and aid not
um anything uh interventionist oh okay
yeah yeah i mean listen then we we
continue trading i don't know i mean
listen it starts
what it what ideas do you have
for how through trade you'd like to see
us
support democracy in another country
what's an example for example um if you
look at uh it's called the um commitment
to development index you could see that
it's very interesting the social
democracies and it's an index that
measures how much a country is committed
to
helping uh
develop
developing countries uh and you look and
it has six metrics if i remember
correctly i don't remember all of them
but it's trade aid technology health um
all of these factors i think are very
important and uh i i don't remember the
us being high up there in the least but
i remember denmark being
pretty high there so that was something
i was interested in can i ask you
another question sure
um so do you have any book
recommendations
uh sure i mean what fiction non-fiction
what genre economics uh
or non-fiction economics that i'm sorry
i should've specified non-fiction
economics let's see i uh what have i
read recently i read a book
by um esther duflo
and abajit banerjee
called
uh what was the name of the book
uh hold on a second this was a good
economics book
um it wasn't oh good economics for hard
times i would recommend that that's a
that's a sort of somewhat new
um economics book i've read that i
thought was quite good also angus deaton
recently wrote let me see if i can find
the name of the book
uh the great escape
um which is a really good book the the
great escape by angus deaton it's
actually nine years old and then also
deaths of despair
by angus deaton i would recommend both
of those as well okay
oh yeah i'm familiar with angus detona
it's pretty interesting and i i've yet
to read these books but um i'll show
i'll be sure to read them beautiful
thank you how's the weather in israel is
it nice
weather in israel uh is pretty bipolar i
mean
like uh we had
pretty huge rains which is pretty good
for israel because uh it's a pretty dry
country you know the kinet which is the
sea or the lake i should say uh
shrinking but then we have rain so it's
getting bigger so that's a good thing
but then we had like a period of a month
or so where it was like relatively
hotter and then the rains came back
yesterday i don't know what's happening
wow are you are you in what part of the
country are you in
so i am in ashkelon near ashkelon i
should say but it's um sort of
in the
south center of the country but then um
i went to uni from the idf uh i went to
uni they subsidized it so that's in the
north like that's in the other half of
the of the country uh so and now i went
back for a month back to my home and i'm
gonna go back in the 20th of march um
back to the technion well a lot a lot
going on i think wolf blitzer's from
ashkelon i don't know why that's in my
mind i think but don't quote me on that
peleg okay i appreciate the call
okay have a good one all right there's
peleg from ashkelon correction wolf
blitzer reported extensively from
ashkelon but he was actually born in
germany so i want to make sure that i
clarify that just in the interest of
clarity this evening
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below